since your channel is called Theory of
Everything I'll say The Theory of
Everything if I can describe it in one
sentence is this process of contraction
and expansion
so when you go through a spiritual path
when you start to meditate and when you
start to pierce through the veil of
Illusion and get into the emptiness of
things
each time you have an opening each time
you pierce through the veil of Illusion
and get an opening into the true nature
the battle of the space of true nature
some of your subconscious and your
traumas and conditions whatever is
separating you from this vast space just
this more solidified version of this
space uh surfaces so you're making the
unconscious conscious or you bring the
shadow to the light so when the shadow
is brought on to the light
um you are forced to look at your stuff
right so you can be very uncomfortable
another way to look at Dark Knight of
the soul is the process of the
dissolution of the ego so if you look at
ego as sort of like a program or a
matrix when it gets attacked we start
doing some meditation practice and you
started seeing through it how the ego is
not what you really are when that
program is undergoing attack it's going
to cling on to itself harder because you
know like any other program if he gets
attacked by a virus it's going to do
everything it's powered to survive so
that process can be extremely
uncomfortable so a lot of people they
meditate and meditate oh everything's
great but then suddenly they go into
this state of depersonalization where
they have a glimpse of their true nature
their emptiness of things but then the
other half of them like they have one to
put an empty there's another first star
in the world they have one foot in you
know the vast spaciousness on the
groundless ground and then they still
have another foot in the ground so
there's two are trying to hold on to the
ground they're still trying to hold on
to their equal identity while at the
same time having some kind of glimpses
into the infinite nature of reality
so that's where the Dark Knight of the
cell comes from it's when you expand and
then you contract back again you feel
very uncomfortable
it's kind of like a a withdrawal from
like a really good psychedelic trip or
like you know a bad trip or something
like that
yeah it's like once you once you
experience God in Divinity now you get
to experience hell until you just send
them both
because they cannot exist without the
other you know people talk about like
you know experiences of Love experience
of God all those great mystical
explosions oh my Consciousness exploded
to the universe that's [__] great now
I feel like a god but then the other
side of that coin is the contraction you
can have expansion with that contraction
that's the loss of nature do you also
have to embrace and stay equanimous to
the experiences of Darkness the soul and
see how this process of expansion and
contraction are two sides of the same
coin and that can be transcended this
has been brought up plenty and he's been
interviewed before Leo Guru what where
do you feel like you comport and where
do you feel like you disagree
uh I haven't watched this video since a
while actually I used to watch his
videos when he talks about
um like how to do selfie inquiry and
things like that I found him to be very
useful until
um I don't know about four three or four
years ago I just I haven't really
watched a lot of his videos
yeah
um but from what I know little garage
talks a lot about the the god
Consciousness thing right
yeah so
in my stages of Awakening I like to
um categorize even though ultimately
there is no levels to this thing but
then up to the process I have the five
stages of Awakening the first stage is
the Eco phase that's when your
identification is with the ego mag
that's pretty much everybody if they
haven't you know you know discovered
that they're not the ego so once you
discover that you're not the ego
the ego started to dissolve it's
literally the body mass sort of dissolve
and you open up the space of awareness
more and now you can abide in the
witness that's the second phase what I
call the witness phase the witness
Consciousness so that's
when you identify with being this
witness the last meditation like
one-on-one but when we first start to
read the power up now I could totally
ask you to like you know be aware of
your thoughts you know your thoughts now
you are the the witness of your thoughts
just shifting your identity from the ego
to the witness but the witness is
actually just a solar version of the ego
Because by the Winner's phase you still
have a lot of solidity you have a little
bit of space but still a lot of solidity
and then you keep dissolving that Center
Point your teeth get dissolving the this
lady of the body mind and the space
opens up more
and then now you enter the third phase
the third stage what I call uh God
Consciousness or Affinity or being
that's the evidence face now you
experience everything to be you
but at this point even though the uh the
solidity in the center is still not
completely dissolved it's very thin now
it's very subtle it's very tiny
so when the solidity in the body mind
becomes very tiny the space opens up
even more so what happens during that
phase is a lot of people they will cling
on to that vast spaciousness and
attribute their identity to
everythingness so that's why a lot of
people start to say they're God or that
um I am everything I am infinite
Consciousness which I went to the same
phase myself
um and then I think it's at this phase
um that a lot of people attribute their
experiences to the nature of reality
yeah okay now because the rest of the
solidity the rest of the ego is still
you know somewhere in your field of
experience even though now it's very
tiny it's still going to take credit or
cling on to this fast spaciousness or
any kind of spiritual insights or
experience that you have and make it
into a thing ratify it and objectify it
and
um theorize some kind of a theory into a
natural reality because this fast basis
is so prominent it's like the only thing
to be real for you at this point but
even at that stage there's more to go
um you consider the solution now you
enter nothing in space this is what I
call the emptiness phase
so now your identity is shrinked down to
almost like an atom now but then you
there's still a little bit of you that's
trying to cling on to emptiness
so each stage you have a ground so the
point is to use one graph to dissolve
the previous ground till all ground is
off and you become the groundless ground
and it's just fully falling
and then the fifth stage is what I call
the natural state
so the natural state is the complete
merging and the Transcendence of all the
previous four stages
so I'm not suppressing any stages or I'm
not saying any stages are wrong I'm just
saying that um you can get stuck in one
of those stages and then the the final
realization is actually that the merge
and the Transcendence of all the stages
so some traditions focus on one stage
one the others for example if you talk
to the Hinduism school like the
non-duality school they focus on the The
Infinite Space more than the Buddhists
even though even though if you take just
one stage and Max it out you are going
to have the same insiders if you take
the everything in his face and Max it up
you are going to reach the same spot as
they emptiness face in stage four and
the Buddhists tend to focus more on the
emptiness phase
yeah so that's why you get a lot of
debate uh
over the over the course of history
about like the new Avita School versus
the Buddhism school you know the
Buddhism school would be like oh uh the
new Avada people didn't go deep enough
they haven't realized that also Brahma
is also empty Brahma is also just
another fabrication
that Brahman is also just another ground
right and the the um the brahmana school
or the Hindu school would be like oh the
Buddhas they haven't realized the the
Infinite Space of consciousness
right but then I think I actually think
that the natural state is sort of like
the merging of those two stages or even
the stages before that
um so in a sense that why I describe the
natural state is kind of like the the
permanent merging of a premisation and
infinite Consciousness so you're taking
two schools both the Buddhism there's
nothing in school and the uh the Hindu
School the the god Consciousness School
uh the awareness school and then you
immerse them together
so should people practice Tantra without
protections such as empowerments of
hereka and shakamuni
I'm not sure what they are but I know a
little bit about the tandrick school
versus the the you know the the suta
school the Tantra School focuses more on
the form side of things
and even the uh I think the badgerana uh
of this ocean school they focus more on
the ground like they focus more on the
awareness part of it and Buddhists will
focus more on just seeing through the
emptiness of everything includers are
trying to attack things from just from
from the pure emptiest perspective and
the the zochan the vagina score are
going from the form they're going to
perform to emptiness in a sense
but again they're actually talking about
the same thing just like the the Hindus
and the nearby time the ocean people
talk about the true self and Buddhism
talking about no self but no self is
true self because when you straight down
to nothing you also everything kind of
thing right so that's why like all the
stages are valid it's just like you know
some schools tend to focus that their
techniques on what specific [__] by
specific
um
stage than the others because you kind
of have to you know if you if you if
you're a tradition you kind of have to
build your practice around like at least
you know some aspects one aspect of
Awakening over another
but at the end he saw the same thing to
me yeah
to me Tantra is just the taking
emptiness and then putting it back into
form so the reason why people associate
Tundra with sex a lot of I guess a lot
of people do I I did you know about
tundra you're like oh it's just like a
sexual unit right so the reason why sex
is such a big thing in tundra is because
when you actually recognize the
emptiness well you're supposed to
practice Tundra only after Awakening
only after recognize emptiness yeah so
after recognizing emptiness you kind of
go back into the world and engage in
activities that would otherwise trigger
you before so sex for example sex and
love or like relationship stuff it's
like the biggest trigger for most people
because the deepest conditioning for
most humans is sex and love because
we're here to reproduce as biological
organisms so if you can abide in the
right students if you can hold the view
if you can still um a body in the
panoramic awareness during sex instead
of Contracting to just your [__] dick
then maybe your realization is legit
[Music]
so is it safe to I guess you can
practice you can do any kind of
practicing at any stages it's just a
degree of intensity you you might not be
safe to practice like mindfulness you
know like you know any kind of practice
can trigger all kinds of stuff inside
yourself like this it depends on where
you are in your practice and how your
brain is wired and a bunch of different
things so and then what is your
relationship to sex do you find it
intrusive to your path your path of
Enlightenment I used to I used to be a
sex addict
um I used to like fabbing like five
times a day and actually the one of the
reasons why I got into meditation 10
years and that yeah 10 years ago is
because I my sex drive was so high and
um he was interfering with my life I
wanted to use meditation to kind of you
know make my sex drive a little bit
lower
um well to me sex is a catharsis right
again going back to expression
contraction like the only reason why we
want to have an orgasm other than to
feel Unity I guess that's the same thing
is to feel to feel expended to feel unit
unified with another person
so in a sense
um
without that contraction sex plays a
very different role after realization
because I guess you could say Awakening
or truth realization is the ultimate
catharsis because you're so relaxing
like you know you're you're your being
is so vast and spacious and balanced
that you don't need to contract and then
expand again in a sense right because in
a sense in a sense
I like to call the state that I'm in
right now
um just the universe [__] itself 24
7. yeah so when the universe is [__]
yourself 24 7 because it just feels like
it's like without solidities in the body
map without you know the center that's
filtering experience experience is
experience in itself without the
experiencer and when that happens it
just feels like every moment is
penetrating itself
so when every moment is penetrating
itself
um the role of sex becomes something
that isn't a necessity anymore like
before at least for me because I was
such a huge sex addict before I couldn't
live without sex I was like you know if
I can choose between living uh the rest
of life not having sex or dying right
now I'll probably choose dying right now
so sex was like so it was like survival
for me right but then nowadays just like
well it's cool to like have sex but then
if I don't have it like I don't think
about it
yeah it's it's kind of like you know
you know the preference over like you
know water or Diet Coke you know like
you can still have preference sometimes
for Diet Coke but then you can quench
the Thirds with water
it's not a necessity anymore yeah all
right man getting back to this daily
routine what's your workout routine on
my workout routine right now is I just
do whatever the gym yeah because uh I
used to be like a pretty
um I used to work out like a lot and
that's actually why I got into spiritual
as well it's just because I wanted to
like upgrade myself it's not like
self-improvement and stuff like that
yeah and the little did I realized they
also messed up the Improvement is
self-destruction
so in a way Fitness is like kind of like
self-destruction too you know let's take
the the example of Fitness since we're
talking about Fitness so the reason why
I wanted to work out is because I wanted
to feel connected to other humans
so I wanted to grow a bigger uh I wanted
to grow bigger muscles and get stronger
because you know I wanted to connect
with other humans because I'll have to
upgrade myself I wanted to upgrade
myself so I can connect with other
humans so that's why I got into
spirituality
yesterday and build bigger muscles
um so I could you know just be like
superhuman and I was like oh okay if you
want to be superhuman you can exclude
the mind you know you have to like
upgrade your Consciousness too you have
to like upgrade your brain so I started
to realize philosophy and all kinds of
stuff and get into like you know
especially the philosophy of the mind
yeah and then after getting into the
possible with my I started getting the
psychedelics after psychedelics I was
like maybe there is a way to permanently
kind of access those higher mystical
States Of Consciousness without
psychedelics so I got into meditation so
as a part of this process of
self-development I started to meditate
and kind of like how you wanted to get
bigger muscles when you work out in
meditation you're expanding yourself
right it could be spending yourself
until you become everything but then
again going back to the process of
expansion contraction if you want to
become everything you have to also
become nothing
so self-improvement taken to the extreme
level is self-destruction
so you can only Truly find the self when
you lost yourself
yeah what would be a more superior
definition of enlightenment the
definition of alignment to me is just
recognize what you really are at the
deepest level like what you really are
that said just recognizing the nature of
experience
and the nature of experience doesn't
have a solidified entity behind anything
there's no thinker here Observer doer
Seer inside the head there's no Avatar
inside the head that's directing your
experience there's no one in the
driver's seat so to speak so in in a
sense Enlightenment is about
deconstructing that solidity in the
center again going back to these obvious
solidity is to deconstruct that observer
in the head that's looking out to the
world
and they realized that the Universe has
always just been perceiving itself
without a center
right Frank I'm gonna be frank you have
a rich metaphysics but on your Instagram
man you're like a Greek sculpture
how do you reconcile the two as their
disconnect
there used to be a disconnect yeah there
used to be a disconnect but then that
was only because I haven't fully
integrated form with emptiness
because like nothing is excluded even
with uh realization like nothing is
excluded from Infinity everything is
okay everything is part of it right so
just because you have a nice physique it
doesn't speak it doesn't determine your
um level of realization in a sense I
mean there there was a phase when I was
like still like in in the no man's land
where I haven't integrated the inside
have it integrated The Emptiness inside
into form completely yet and now every
time I work out I feel very contracted
I'm doing this for the ego or like you
know uh this is like a detrimental to my
spiritual process and spiritual progress
but then that's only because the rest of
the the ego will say that the rest of
the ego was making a story out of that
like reality itself doesn't doesn't make
that distinction
like everything is part of that you know
you can be a 300 pound bodybuilder pure
muscle the five percent body fat is
still be like enlightened this
absolutely uh there's nothing off limit
with Enlightenment really yeah you can
do whatever but then some people take
that to the extreme and they just start
doing like really shady stuff but that's
another conversation
laughs so then how is it that you handle
negative emotion
the way I experience negative emotions
is that I don't quantify I don't
experience them as negative nor positive
they're just kind of neutral it's just
when I experience quote unquote negative
emotions they barely arise nowadays but
sometimes if they do arise experience
just like smoke that's like puffing
within this bad spaciousness so any kind
of emotion both positive and negative
because you know they can't why can't I
exist without the other all emotions are
experienced as like wind blowing through
the sky once you've become the sky the
wind like it doesn't really affect the
sky even though it can be there
like the weather can still go through
like this uh process of transformation
because nature again undergoes through
the process of expression contraction
all the time so you can still have good
weathers and bad weathers but if you're
a body in the sky if you become the sky
which is the nature of mind
um it you're not affected by the weather
but the weather can still be there
so every sensation is so liberate
it's only when you cling onto Sensations
that you that you create suffering so XI
Jin young said suffering is pain times
resistance right you can still have
clinical negative emotions arise but
then if you don't cling onto them if you
don't identify with them if you don't
resist them they're not manifested as
suffering
do you believe yourself to be
enlightened
um
like I don't know if I I don't know if I
want to answer that question because why
it
I mean it depends on your definition of
our ship
yeah yeah
um okay the the most direct the most
direct definition of arha ship uh which
is the the clinical highest level of
Awakening in according to a servata map
so I'm only going to talk about this
from servata map right because we talk
about this words like enlightenment
especially Enlightenment you know
different people Define it differently
so I'm just gonna go with our hardship
because it's more it's more
contextualized right so the the simplest
definition of an R Hub according to the
Buddha is insanely in the same without a
seer in in the heart only the hearing
without the hearer in the hurdling the
heart and the scene in the scene right
uh in the thinking only thinking without
the Thinker so basically what he's
trying to say is uh lyric direct
experience after you've dissolved the
nozzle perception in the center of your
head or somewhere in your body
so if you look at it from that
perspective then yes because I haven't
had a sense of a hearer center or
Observer or perceiver or a sense of doer
in two years
yeah so in my experience every single
sensation is just uh perceiving itself
without a center so the awareness is
this kind of this is one periodic field
where every cent store is is Unified
into this one field and every sensation
within it are uh perceiving itself since
it is of
yeah
and that realization is permanent so I
don't know it's very weird it's just
like once the center drops it's dropped
by permanently it's literally [__]
weird I can like drink a bunch of
alcohol I still have no setter
but then again sometimes conditioning
can still rise but then again there are
perceived to be with our location
they're just kind of like again wind
blowing the sky like where is the wind
in the sky is it in a certain location
you can't find it like there's a sense
of a locatability and a sense of
um ungraspability you can't grasp it
it's there but you can't grasp it it's
kind of like the rainbow you know the
rainbow is there but not there right
that's how I perceive things though
what occurs after death what happens I
don't know
I don't really think about death yeah
well in a sense I don't know I the whole
notion of life versus death it doesn't
make sense that much to me anymore
because
you kind of transcend The Duality
between existence and non-existence you
realize they're just Concepts
yeah like life cannot exist without
death so I don't know if this is life or
death I don't really know like you know
there's not these things you put in life
and death in my experience because I
don't even know what life is honestly
how do you see the universe do you think
about how it's all structured and where
are places within it uh uh yes and no
like I used to think about that a lot
especially like
like I said earlier when when you when
you undergo into this process when you
direct experience you're walking around
Waking Life Experiences like
dramatically altered you start to like
formulate all kinds of theories about
the universe but they're all most of
that is still just a projection of your
ego
are psychedelics than a useful tool for
reaching certain States sure yeah
are great tools but psychedelics to me
again it's just a tool for you to
dissolve the solar in the body mind and
again all the special experiences I
experience on psychedelics uh are no
different than special States and
mystery experiences you experience when
you're meditating or when you like lucid
dreams or would you like have a
Kundalini explosion like I went through
the space where like my whole chakra
when like every shotgun in my body
opened up and then I was obsessed with
Kundalini for a while I was like holy
[__] I had a Kundalini Awakening and I
started looking up you know just
literature about kamilini like open up a
third eyes and then I realized that
opening up a third eye is only a means
to an end
you you're opening up the third eye so
you can perceive the wisdom iron and
when I say the wisdom eye what I mean is
just emptiness
so what the Kundalini is is pretty much
just the dissolution of all the
conditions in the traumas that are
stored in your body and for some reason
all the traumas are stored you know in
very specific places like in your spine
like you know the the chakra so I
experienced all those shortcuts open it
up and at that moment I was like holy
[__] this is like this is a that's when
I was realized that you you can
experience um
mystical States and states of
Consciousness that are as powerful as
psychedelics just by you know meditation
just by
um it's all been the solidity in the
body of my through the passionate or
whatever techniques that you use
so after I went through all that I
realized that there's no distinction at
all between psychedelic experiences and
like genres or like somebody's and any
kind of like meditative absorptions
they're just to buy products and the
symptoms and the side effects of that
dissolution so that the way I look at
kind of late explosion it's like
tripping on your own condition so if you
take a lot of psychedelics if you cling
onto those experiences or you your ego
contextualize those experiences not even
in psychedelics but even in meditation
if your ego cleans on to those
experiences that make a thing out of
them or create a new identity out of
them
um they just pilot more conditioning
you're not actually making progress well
like for most people like they
regardless of how much musical
experience is that you're getting if
you're if you're a practice and you are
going to make progress but you can
easily get sidetracked by those
experiences the way I look at like
psychological experiences or made
economistic experiences or energy stuff
kind of leaning like dreams or like
going to other dimensions Alias entities
is
looking at it from the perspective of
the two axis of development in terms of
uh the path of Awakening so with
Awakening you're you're going from the
source of Consciousness sorry you're
going from the surface level
Consciousness to the source of
Consciousness that's the x-axis of the
bottom
so you're going straight down to the
source if you're a non-dual practitioner
or like if you follow the the teachings
of like Ramana mahashi or nasakada
they're just you know that's why it's
called direct method you're going
straight to the source disregard all the
experiences that you ever come across on
Australia path you realize they're all
part of the dream you go straight to the
source but in the in the vertical sorry
the horizontal axis is your like cities
and now Mr experiences energetic stuff
most people when they go down to the
source or at least they try to get on
the source if you call this Awakening
you are going to encounter a lot of
energetic stocks like kind of linearies
and you know John us makes our
experiences so it's Formosa is this like
going down to the source so that's why
even I experience a lot of like
craziness experiences
so so some people though they instead of
going down to the source their
experience are so powerful that they
just get sidetracked so they're actually
just going further away from the store
so they at least they just go they go
that way horizontally
by indulging in those experiences
instead of going downward but that's
okay too because it's good to be a
conscious Explorer you can be a
conscious Explorer without recognizing
the true nature of consciousness
but then like if you if your goal is to
go down to the source and realize your
true nature for most people they are
going to experience those things but you
can use just as easily get trapped in
those experiences and just go that way
just go horizontally without ever
reaching a source yeah
so that's how I contextualize that's how
I contextualize the difference between
Layman and Mr experiences yeah
there are several people in the world in
the comments section looking for a
Kundalini explosion what advice do you
have well just use the mystical
experiences as a tool for investigation
right so like
to get on the source of Consciousness to
penetrate through the emptiness of
phenomenons you can use anything your
experience to do that
like if you counter a lot of mystical
experiences or um you know see entities
just use them to deconstruct phenomenons
into emptiness
let's see that they're fundamentally the
same thing as perceiving a rock or
you're imagining uh a rock or uh
or having a dream or you know eating ice
creams
they're them out of the same stuff yeah
I mean I don't I think Mexico
experiences are great I think that
experience is a wonderful yeah I I think
they're kind of like it's kind of like
boot out just would throw candies that
you on the path It's like because like
when you go down to the source of
consciousness for most people the more
like mystical experiences you're going
to have because the more you're dissolve
the deeper into the into the nature of
reality or nature of my you're you're
you're going
so
it's actually for a lot of people at
least for me personally it's a sign of
progress actually
even though it could be a distraction
for a lot of people it's at the same
time
um it's a sign of progress a lot of
people so like Buddha is throwing
candies on the path and then you eating
like okay I'm going the right direction
it's a little reward but then don't get
don't cling on to them just keep calling
there are places like shrines and at
least ostensibly sacred temples and
people
meditate in proximity to it so what role
does this proximity play
are these places indeed sacred
um ultimately
not they're they don't really play that
much abroad I mean you you can attain
the same Insight sitting in your bedroom
as like the holiest places in the world
yeah
I mean you're looking inward to the
nature of mind until you flip yourself
inside out right so you can do that
um anywhere and when you do flip
yourself inside out everywhere is the
same like I used to go on this I used to
um
I used to go to temples and then just
feel like super euphoric and be like
holy [__] this place has super Good
Vibes like oh I feel like my spirit's
full of like
um my spiritual muscle just got bigger
just by being in this Tempo when I see a
statue of a Buddha I would get like
Goosebumps but now when I see a statue
of Buddha I just see a rock like I just
see like empty Rock like it's not
different than perceiving this water
bottle yeah like sitting my sitting
Stillness in my home just for meditating
or not meditating it's no different than
like filming in the city of New York for
like 12 hours a day it's just the same
thing it's the same Stillness same vast
spaciousness so ultimately it doesn't
make a difference but if you're still on
the path you can use that as an anchor
you can use like
um temples and even
basically every single spiritual tools
is an anchor you use one anchor to
dissolve another anchor until all
anchors dissolve themselves but then
ultimately the entire spiritual Paradigm
has to be transcended like you realize
the entire spiritual paradigm
um
this is just another fabrication it's
just a tool for you to use and like
because that said you know you use your
use the letter to climb
um this mountain and then after you
climb to the top of the mountain you you
throw at the ladder you don't need it
anymore
like even the Buddha said something
similar it's like um they put us that
even empty this is empty what he means
is that even the whole Dharma is all
teaching is empty it's our teaching is
just a tool fabricated for you to use so
that you can realize your true nature
but once you utilize your true nature
you realize that the entire Paradigm of
spirituality is actually no different
than any other paradigms any other
programs it's a program that you use to
destroy all other programs but in and of
itself it's just another program that
you have to just send but a lot of
people get into spirituality they never
got through that program of spirituality
like they would deconstruct and dissolve
all the other programs now that I'm the
spiritual being you know nice to be a
sex add AI to be in the pickup program I
used to be the gym program I used to be
in the artist program and then I
dissolved all that but now I'm still in
the spirituality program
that you're not completely free yet
because he's just trapped in
spirituality but then you saw you have
to let that go as well but most people
like can let go of the last step because
the last spec of their ego
identification still need to click onto
something
and that something is spirituality for a
lot of people that are on the spiritual
path that's why they they will be into
spirituality for like 10 20 30 years
going to like go and cut Retreats but
they don't seem to
um progress as fast as they'll like yeah
maybe because they're sitting on the
program that they are using you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy